Let's say that we have a 9/10 fraction
And I want to add to it fraction 1/6
How much is the sum of their sum?
When you first look at these two fractions, you'll say
"I have different denominations here
It is not clear to me how to bring them together "
The way is
Find a common denominator
To convert both of these fractions into
Two fractions have the same place
So how do you think about finding a common denominator?
Well, the common denominator between them would be
The common multiplier of these ten and six fractions
Thus, what is the common multiplier of number ten and number six
And often for simplification we find the smaller common multiplier
A good way to find the smallest common multiplier is to start with the largest existing ones
Is the ten, is the ten divided by the six?
No ... Well, will the twenty be divided on the six?
No ... Is the 30 divided by the six? Yes .. Thirty are divided on the six
So all I will do is multiply the ten
Let's say: "What is the smallest multiplier of number ten
The denomination is accepted on the number six "to be equal to the thirty
Thus, we can rewrite the fractions
As a number on the thirtieth
9/10, how we can type it as a number
On the other hand? Well, I'll hit the place
I will hit the place in number three
All I've done is hit the place in number three
If I did not want to change the value of the fraction
I will do the same thing in the rugs
That is, I will multiply the numerator in number three
And because I hit the numerator in number three
It is located in number three
The value of the fracture will not change
Nine hit three equals twenty-seven
Again, 9/10 and 27/30
Represents the same number
He only wrote the fraction with a denominator of 30
I can also type fraction 1/6
In a place equal to 30. Let's do it
1/6 is a number of thirty, what is this number?
I encourage you to stop the video and try to think about it
What will we do to move from the six to thirty?
We'll hit him in the five
Therefore, if we hit the place in the five
We will also beat the rugs in the five
One hit five equals five
Thus, the 9/10 fraction is like 27/30 fraction
A fraction of 1/6 is like a 5/30 fraction
Now we can bring them together
it is clear that
We have a certain number of 30 parts
In addition to a number of other 30 parts
Thus, 27/30 plus 5/30 will be 27
It will be 27 plus 5
27 plus five on thirty
Of course it will become equal
For breaking 32/30
If we want to simplify this break
We have common factors between 32 and 30
Both are divided by the two
Therefore, if we divide the ridge and place on two
The division of the numerator into two is equal to sixteen
The denomination of the denominator on two equals fifteen
Thus, it is equal to 16/15
To write it as a fractional number, the division of sixteen to fifteen is one
And the rest is one
If this represents the number 1/15 1
Let us put another example
Suppose we want to collect
1/2 to
11/12
I encourage you to turn off the video
To see if the answer could be found
As we have seen previously, we want to find
Common denominator
If the fractures have the same place
We can combine them directly
But we want to find a common place
Because the properties are now unequal
If we want to find it is the multiplier
The smaller common multiplier of number two and twelve
We will find the smaller common multiplier for two and twelve
Like what we did before, we'll start bigger than
These two pillars are twelve
Now we can say twelve hit one equals twelve
The Twelve is the smallest multiplier of the same
And accept the division on the two? Yes sure
Twelve accept the division on the two
Thus, the twelve is actually the smallest common multiplier between the two and the twelve
We can write both of these fractions
As a number on the twelve
1/2 is a number of the twelve What is this number?
Well, let's go from the two to the twelve we hit in number six
Also we will multiply the numerator in number six
Now see that 1/2 fraction is like 6/12 fraction
One is half of the two and six is ​​half of the twelve
How can we write the fraction 11/12 as a number on the twelve?
Well, it is already written as a number on the Twelve
If 11/12 you have twelve
Therefore, we will not change the fraction 11/12
So now we can combine
If this equals six
Equals six plus eleven
Six plus eleven on twelve
On a dozen, if we have 6/12 plus 11/12
Become six plus eleven on twelve
Equal to 17/12
If we want to write it in the form of fractional number
The division of the seventeen on the twelve equals one
The rest is five if this equals 5/12 1
Let us also solve another issue
Strangely, this is fun
Suppose we want to collect
3/4 to
We'll collect 3/4 to 1/5
1/5
How much is the sum of their sum?
Again, stop the video
And see if you can solve it
Well, here we have different temples
We want to find or want to rewrite the fractions
In the same place
Therefore, we must find a common multiplier
Ideally, we have to find the smallest common multiplier
What is the smallest common multiplier between the four and five numbers
Well, we'll start with the largest number of items
And look at its multiples
Until we reach a number that is divided by four
Five can not divide by four
Ten can not be divided by four or can not be divided by four completely
We will not care about them
Fifteen are not fully divided on the four
Twenty are divided by four, in fact twenty are four in five
If what we can do we can write
Both of these fractions are in the form of a fracture that possesses the denominator of 20
If we can write 3/4 as a number on 20
Therefore, let us go from four to twenty in the place
We'll hit five
Also we will do it in rugs
Three hit five equals fifteen
All I did for the transfer from four to twenty in the denominator, is multiplication in number five
And we do the same in rugs
Three in five equals fifteen
The fraction 15/20 represents the same fraction 3/4
1/5 is a number of twenty, what is this number?
Well, let's go from five to twenty we'll beat in four
And we do the same thing in the rugs
When the numerator is hit in four, the fracture becomes equal to 4/20
Therefore, we rewritten 3/4 plus 1/5
To 15/20 plus 4/20
How much is the sum of their sum?
Fifteen plus four on twenty equals 19/20
It's 19/20 and it's over